jol herzlich willkommen zu diesem video
wir spielen halt mal was ganz neues und
zwar nenne ich das jetzt einfach mal
habe ich nahm dafür acht egal
und zwar kenne ja das ist immer wo man
so eine zahl in die luft hält und dann
ist das beispiel 9 in dem fall müsste
ich und mein team made der gute alte
decken jetzt die zahl neun hier nehmen
und das sind zwar ein paar stunden
gewählt werden wir wechseln uns ab sind
zweierteams das betteln geht zehn
minuten im gegnerischen team ist einmal
der gute alte tobi ich bin ich alt und
bin ich alt aber gut machen ach so weiß
es genau
hallo da die beiden klubs dieses im ort
nicht haben springt die king für die ein
und ich bring für unser team und ich
fange jetzt mal für unser team an und
wir haben ja die sieben komplizen sven
biete das ist auch ihre aber schon eine
shotgun you know how to attack hallo
hallo
nur eins weil ich die regel dass man
nicht die regel dass war die regel
okay das ist die regel gewesen ja jetzt
ok dafür dann wird sie sehen aus als
wären diese passten also da gibt es
keine waffe das 343 etwas bord haben
müssen
wir brauchen eigentlich beides der
gewinn also 58 kanal eine einzige
programm so heftigen wir haben halt nur
grüne und blaue und glaube sagt ihr seid
jetzt mal ganz kurz hier eingeblendet
wie der not ball im tor ist ihm aussieht
okay das epische zwei gegen zwei duell
gegen tobias wenn beginnt jetzt 32 uhr
okay weil ich muss an waffen sortieren
um mein gott dann müsst ihr auch einfach
alleine weg kürzen oder ich weiß nicht
was dein plan ist
vorher war das 1 1
platz und ist entgegen gestellt wer hat
es geklappt
tut mir leid ich weiß nicht 1 1 an dass
wir so weit so gut
das problem ist wir haben gar kein
problem
die hab ich gesagt peking ist das 1874
war so unnötig
wo ist denn täglich sieben ich weiß es
nicht ich hab ich nicht hören die ganze
zeit junge tobias kade sowie tobi die
irgendwie beschlossen dass man so
steffen kurz
er kommt hinter hinterher
ein alter mann
das heißt du bist ok
du hast einen fisch kopf geht es denn
dass das waren 8 ich will ja nicht sagen
dass wir bessere waffe haben aber
irgendwie habe es gerade so wie man es
hätte mich fast wickelte junge ich will
doch nur gerade tun ist wenn kinder in
alter
das waren 4 fast hätte sich 6210
das war's mit dem verkehr ist habt ihr
insgesamt denke ich hatte drei kids
heißt wenn du das auch kiels aber wir
haben gleich schon gewonnen also ich hab
mir egal was ihnen jetzt noch mal runter
bis gleich jetzt geht es weiter mit 102
ich würde behaupten diesmal fängt de
ging an für das team und tobi uns wenn
es ist es gar nicht so wir haben die
vielen was ist das ja gefährdet
es ist sowohl hehl ich bin etwas das so
geil jungs pistolen
das hatte ich ihr gold mein ding ich auf
seinem podest stand naja da man kein
goldenes glaube da macht spaß diese
beiden waffen hatte diesmal oder jetzt
ist fast die wir haben alles okay ist
nicht schlecht die eigentlich als weg
gebracht
ich glaube aber die tatsache dass ihr
die nicht haben können naja nein
untersagt
wir haben all diese projekte lutins gibt
also und goldfarben die leute die fahren
hier metz und die sind hier unterwegs
tobias und sven hier am start wir sind
ja gar kein formel 1 rennen sonst also
wie lange abidal der ersten ersten
kollegen genau so arbeitet man das ziel
irgendwann selber wissen
auch die kapo liebst du denn rom gereist
aber lächerlich
wie sehe ich nicht mal da das hat
einfach lächerlich
thomas der daytona
wenn nicht sterben ich habe gut gezogen
aber erschießt mich ab allerdings zeit
unfassbar
ich gehe meinen weg ich bin jetzt hier
das neue junge liegt der heavy machst du
hast dein ding hier nennt das thomas
mann
allerdings funktioniert sven konzack
ich werde mit einer reife abgeschlossen
nein verletzten fünf minuten leute kommt
thomas schießt nicht auf den kurs
was da ist und wie viel hast du noch
hier schießt ein foto ist er kaputt ist
richtig mir sowas noch überholen und das
3gs zugeben ich habe herr alto wie das
ist so unnötig wollte sich jetzt nur
kennen damit die nächtliche fällen haben
oder conan ehrenhaft und ehrenhaft ich
bin gut gefallen da kann ich nichts
drauf wieder als wenn dann alles ok ist
nicht gerade hatte ich habe es doch
geklappt ich kann nicht mehr lange
dauern
das vertrauen ist da kommen noch zwei
minuten alle kommen dürfen das nicht
gewinnen
das gibt's doch nicht das bei dir jetzt
sind da natürlich was erwartest du weißt
ich hatte noch nie erleben und erst ein
motto hallo in der luft schießen
verboten verlusten schließlich mein baby
kann sie die treffen
ohmann com ist so cool dass dafür seien
nämlich gegangen hätte das am ende
tobias du ich habe es werden wir das tun
können
das heißt ihr ab 17 und 13 hahaha alles
klar damit haben die auf jeden fall
besser früher gewonnen das war ein
bisschen er hat gewinnen lassen müsst
ihr ja also ich habe auch nicht gewusst
dass tobi so gut ist natürlich auch dass
mit diesem video vielen dank dass sie
dabei wenn ihr bock habt ihr mich auf
diese weise zu begleiten abonniert doch
gern den kanal und schaut auch auf jeden
fall war tobi vorbei und da ist wenn
vorbei und dann abonniert doch gern
diesen kanal dann sehen wir zunächst
wieder macht's gut
[Musik]